great shot great pass by lee just  unselfish basketball that's hard to  guard green  the reverse  even likes bringing luka in they have  like three guards with these guys  here's dinwiddie step back three yes  because he didn't give you see although  you've seen dinwiddie here  getting into his back to a step back  three  [Music]  and you're gonna continue to see bertans  setting the screen  one  because the floor is wide open finney  smith with a great catch and shoot three  okay here comes jordan poole and golden  state you know the one thing i liked  about that play is something we talked  about earlier with luca oh great block  and the lead working on curry  fade away  fade away  and the shooters touch touching  he knocks yes as he goes down court  dodging  working one-on-one with curry  dinwiddie  got it at the  buzzer dodges that's 27 then winning 24.  here's john  off the glass  down the whole game  but luka doncic and the mavs now up six